那我们去做一些不关于体育，不关于游泳，不关任何我们当下所做的事情。
我们抛开这些，我们去体验别的生活。
我们去看看风景，我们去喝喝咖啡，或者说我们去尝一尝当地的一些茶。
然后感受一下当地的文化，这样的方式方法。
因为这样的方式，在大家可能最后看到了一分五十六秒，一六的这么一个成绩。
它总是会爽，come on， yeah， 叮住。
对，就其实在你最想放弃的时候，有队友给你这么一句鼓励。
你真的会觉得有被安慰到，然后有人在支撑你的感觉。
因为我很喜欢说话，所以有时候，就像顺座说的，在小时候你在学里面游的时候，你巴不得赶快到边。
然后跟身边的训练伙伴一起去讲，就是你在游的时候脑子里想的东西去分享。
在我们路上，很多力量训练当中，我们就其实大家练着练着，不自觉的，就会去比较。
就比如说，我加重一点，我再加重一点，或者我多做两个。
就是用比较会，也是能激发豆子，激发自己潜力的，我觉得。
各位好，欢迎来到Lemon对话好状态，我是主持人冷剑国。
不知道你在运动的时候，身边有没有这样一个人，因为太懂你，所以让你无法舒适。
你想放弃的时候，他一眼看穿，你说今天有点累，他知道哪次是真的累，哪次是偷懒。
你已经做得很好了，他让你发现你还能更好，太懂你的人有时候真的挺烦的。
但这种烦不是讨厌的烦，更像是对有之间太熟悉，太了解之后，才会有的一种提醒和推动。
今年Lemon想传递的运动精神是感受，一起的好感受，从比赛到日常训练。
其实我们都鼓励大家不只是关注结果，更关注人在运动中，在团队里感受到的支持，连结和快乐。
而今天来到节目的四位嘉宾，也许正是这种感受很好的注视。
他们在训练，比赛和生活里长期陪伴彼此，也是彼此身边那种又烦又懂，又离不开的队友。
欢迎游泳运动员汪顺，叶时文，张义祥和何俊逸。
今天四位一起坐在这里其实有点像对里的一次小小聚会，为了让我们的听众先认识一下你们之间的关系呢？
我们今天就换一种打招呼的方式，我想先请小叶、小张、小和分别跟大家打个招呼。
再用一句话介绍一下你眼里的汪顺，他在对里是一个什么样的人，你们平时是怎么称呼他的呢？
小叶先来吧？
好，哈喽，大家好，我是游泳运动员叶时文，然后我眼里的顺歌就是一个非常自律，非常专注，同时又很幽默的人。
哈喽，我是游泳运动员张义祥，然后我眼里的顺歌是一个非常热情，然后非常会帮助我们的好大哥。
大家好，我是游泳运动员何俊逸，我眼中的顺歌，它是对里面的好榜样。
它是一名优秀的运动员，当然也不乏，它是我们一位很热心的朋友。
这样面对面夸会不会让汪顺有点不好意思，最后也请汪顺跟听众朋友打个招呼。
哈喽，大家好，我是汪顺，很开心今天和大家一起在这里和大家稍微聊聊天，然后分享一下我们平时的一些状态。
其实在我的印象中，无论是小爷爷还是张义祥还是何俊逸，我们都是非常好的队友。
我们一直在训练中度过了非常许多艰难的时刻和困难的时刻，当然越是困难越是艰难的时刻越让我们鸣起于心。
无论是开心还是快乐，我们一直都在一起想见走。
那游泳运动员的生活其实跟我们普通人的生活不太一样，你们训练、比赛、吃饭、休息，很多时间都是跟队友在一起度过的。
那这样长期的紧密的相处下来，你们觉得在游泳队的生活里最特别的和外界的人想象的不一样的点是什么呢？顺哥能跟我们说说吗？
其实我们作为运动员，我们的生活相比外面来说会更枯燥一点。
大家可能更多的其实是看到我们在赛场上非常展现自己人的每刻，可能短短的一分钟、两分钟，甚至最多可能也就十几分钟的比赛时间吧？
但是在这背后的话，我们一直都是三点一线，日复一日的这样的一个训练方式跟模式。
然后我们更多的其实相处的环境很简单，就是除了教练，那就是队友了。
大家可能都会有一个让自己非常难忘的这么一个瞬间，那我相信就是在校园的这个时光一定会伴随大家在这一辈子里面都有所回忆的。
那对于我们来说，我们可能没有像这样的校园时光，我们可能更多的是我们的队友时光，我们在队里的一些时间。
我们会有许许多多非常好的一些回忆，这些东西也是承载着我们背后发生的一些故事吧？
那刚才听小叶小和和小张评价你的时候用的都是很好的词，就是非常自律啊，非常热心啊？
那其实我们在做这期节目的前采的时候也听到了，大家对你都有一个非常统一的吐槽。
大家说的就是哪哪都有汪顺，训练有他，吃饭有他，打游戏的时候也会突然出现。
那能不能请小叶小和和小张给我们举一个例子，什么叫哪哪都有汪顺呢？
比如说可能我在跟队友聊天的时候，顺哥就默默的出现在我身后，站了很久我都没有发现。
然后突然加入群聊，对对对，就是很有意思。
因为我们运动员生活就是像前面顺哥说的那样，我们跟外面的校园不太一样。
我们平时生活吃饭训练都会呆在一块，然后特别男孩子平时大家就是会撕昏到一块。
所以有时候不管是你坐在电脑桌前还是书桌前，甚至吃饭的时候，顺哥有时候就是会突然入境他会吓你一跳。
他为什么会吓到你们，我们因为他有时候做一些事情的时候会比较认真，他会比较专注。
比如他打游戏的时候他是不会被别人所影响，在你做你自己的事情的时候他就会突然出现来打断你。
并不是每个人都可以做到像他一样不受影响。
早张也有类似的经历吗？
有的，因为其实我们首先我们房间有时候住的非常近。
所以说有些时候顺哥就会来我们房间，然后突然出现，不管我们在干嘛都会过来跟我们玩弄一下。
感觉也很像你们说没有经历过学生时代的大学男生宿舍。
是的，因为我们确实住的非常近，然后大家都会，就像在某天一个中午。
比如说何俊逸在打游戏我进去，可能吓他一下，因为他在非常端住，戴个耳机。
在他可能要非常专注的时候我突然吓他一下，他会带着包袱行李在可能今天晚上的时候回来以后再给我这么来这一下。
对，但是我可能就像他前面说的，我可能专注进去，他可能没有达到他预期想要的效果。
所以这是你跟队友相处跟他们开玩笑的一种方式吗？
是的，这个其实也是我们作为在训练中解决枯燥法，为了这么一个小的生活方式，然后也是一个相处的方式方法。
那其实很多队友关系里都是有彼此竞争的时刻，共同作战的时刻，也有一些让大家放松下来的时刻。
我记得我曾经看到过一个资料是说，小张在第一次见汪顺的时候，他跟你说以后大家都是一个组的了，都是自己人。
这句话当时给你的感觉是怎么样的呢？你当时会因为比如刚刚进入队伍，刚换到一个新环境而觉得紧张吗？
对，会，因为我刚刚进队的时候那个时候年纪也比较小，可能就是14岁，所以说一进来都是一个陌生的环境。
然后周围都是陌生的人，包括像顺哥这样就是比年纪比例大很多的大队员，就心里面还是会很紧张啊，会很忐忑就见他们的时候。
所以这句话让你能够放松下来一点，感觉好像是能够融入这个团队是吗？
对，说完之后就会感觉好像没有想象中的那么距离那么远，就好像很亲近啊，就这种感觉。
那汪顺作为队伍里的大哥会特别注意比如有新人来的时候，我可以去安慰他或者是表示这个队伍对他的接纳和欢迎，会有这种意识吗？
我觉得还是会做的，这个意识我觉得不单单从我这里开始做起的，这个其实我觉得也像是一种传承或者传统。
每当有新队员来的时候，我就说我自己吧，刚进队的时候，那时候的大队员以及教练也都是用非常，他们让人觉得温暖的方式在接纳我进入这个团体。
那我记得我第一次进到这个一线队伍的时候跟着教练练的时候，我当时是住在一楼，我要搬到五楼去。
然后我们教练他让全组的队员都帮着我去办东西，突然那一刻我就感觉我好像不再是一个人了，我好像就融入到那个团体中了。
这让我就是一下子就会有那种归属感在我的内心中，瞬间我觉得我好像被这个团队所接纳了在心理上。
让我对这个团队，对这个团体更有了这个依靠给依赖的一个方向，这个是基于在我内心深处的这么一份力量。
所以说无论是在之后的这个时间里，可能我从这个小队员变成了大队员以后。
也会通过我自己的一些方式让大家加入到这个团体的时候，在心态上心理上有一个这么一个依靠和一个归属感。
那你刚才提到的是大家在生活上的一种相互的关照，一种心理上的彼此的接纳彼此的欢迎。
那我也想知道在训练里你们会不会有这样一种彼此的推动，因为大家都是同行嘛？
其实你很容易识别出，今天你有没有努力，或者是你在进行哪个训练的时候，是不是还可以倒极限了，还是可以再用力一点。
我记得小张之前在描述汪顺的时候，也提到了续续刀刀这个词，好像训练到后期。
这个身体已经快要坚持不住的时候，再听到他讲话会有点听不进去。
小张能描述一下在训练中顺歌那种捞刀续刀的感觉吗？
我觉得其实有些时候是因为顺歌她本身她其实经历会比我们更加旺盛。
尤其到最后比较累的时候她可能会有更多的经历来还会去看我们训练是怎么样的。
并且就给予我们鼓励，或者给予我们一些经验。
所以说其实到那个时候我都很累了，但是顺歌可能就是她还有经历。
她不仅能自己先吃完，她还能来关心我或者说给予我帮助。
汪顺会觉得你对不同的队友会有不同的大眼号的这种捞刀续刀激励他们的方式吗？
我觉得还是会有的，我觉得每个人他都是一个非常独立的个体，大家都有不一样的这种性格。
然后无论是在平时生活，当然在训练中，特别在训练中，特别在前面张一翔说到的。
她在极限的时候，大家会产生一些不同的情绪，因为到她身体的极限的时候。
还需要你在坚持，需要你在往前走的时候，有的会不耐烦，有的可能会想要放弃。
有的可能会我想要再尝试一下，大家每个人在面对同样困难的时候都有不同的表现。
所以说对待不同的队友的时候，可能方式也会不一样。
那可能对于，就是我在不行的时候吧，何君毅他会来刺激我。
他说我要把你干掉了，你要做好准备哦。
有这样的方式，其实我们也是一直在相互的激励对方。
提高在当下的训练的一个氛围的一个质量，从而我们获得了更好的结果。
也是通过我们这样子一个方式，大家在训练中一个良心经质。
就像前面我们说到的在生活中，我们可能是大家相互的在互忙互助可能更多一点。
但在训练场上的话，我们还是比较刀人向内的，然后大家争刀争枪的去比评。
那当然这结果还是为了更好的方向，取得了更好的成绩。
那小燕能不能跟我们分享一下，你跟队友之间彼此激烈啊，彼此打气这样的故事或者小瞬间吗？
那就先说说顺哥吧，在我的视角他主要是以鼓励的方式会多一些。
就比如说强度游到最后几个的时候，他总是会说 come on yeah 叮嘱。
对，就其实在你最想放弃的时候，有队友给你这么一句鼓励，你真的会觉得有被安慰到。
然后有人在支撑你的感觉，然后就包括像我们有的时候会穿连体去有一些模拟比赛的强度。
然后顺哥永远是那个气氛担当，就是能够把整个场子的气氛都调动起来。
这会让你有一种我有好多队友好多家人在边上看着我比赛的感觉。
这是因为顺哥是一个艺人吗？一个人营造出了整个啦啦对的感觉。
真的有，真的有
所以队里还是很需要这种艺人来调节气氛，来减慢的是不是？
是的，而且也能缓解一下你做那个模拟测验的紧张感。
我之前看到一个很可爱的故事，是说顺哥有一次跟队友训练50米的时候。
大家互相做了一个假动作，结果只有小和真的有出去了。
所以真的是有这件事情吗？当事人小和能不能跟我们讲一下是怎么被骗着有出去了。
真的有这件事情，居然我们在训练当中，我们会看那个时钟，然后包干自己。
就是顺哥做这个事情的时候，如果没记错的话，那时候好像他都还没有满18岁。
我到现在最后记得的场景就是我登出去之后，主导就是我们的教练。
他在游泳池的对面，人还没有动，但是他的骂声已经过来了。
因为他知道你不认真，所以你会被他们骗出去。
前面有骂声，后面有两个队友的笑声。
反正那一幕我记得挺深的。
就是因为游泳训练，他其实在进行比较认真的训练量的时候，我们都是会比较沉默的。
但是在比较准备活动跟后面的放松阶段的时候，我们在水里面也会整出一些花火。
因为毕竟训练是枯燥的，运动员又是一帮好动的人。
而且其实每天大部分醒着的时间都在训练，对不对。
可能日常的这种玩笑啊，或者是彼此的捉弄，就成了大家生活里的一些乐趣的来源。
是的，哪怕大家在累的时候交流那种疲惫的心得。
因为在水里面有时候可能你说不了太多话，然后当大家其实都沉默认真的去完成这趟训练课的时候。
你可以感受到身边人跟你的通评。
所以你们除了彼此激励，也会互相交流一下，今天的训练真的很累，或者哪一个训练真的有累到我。
对，是每一天都会，就是每一天比如今天你这里有的好，今天我这里完成的好。
然后今天整体一堂课下来的感受是什么，我们每天都会聊。
嗯，这种感觉其实挺好的，因为你刚才提到我们在水下期的时候是没法说话的。
而且大家最开始游泳的时候想必也是都是一个人下水，一个人去学习，一个人去训练。
那后来合作也成为了我们运动生涯很重要的一部分。
我想知道对你们来说，学会如何去合作，如何跟别人生活在一起。
它是不是需要一个过程，是不是也经历了最初的不舒服啊，或者彼此有一些小摩擦，小矛盾。
后面我们慢慢的有了那种一家人的感觉。
是的，我第一次其实从家里面到集体生活，是我八岁的那一年。
那一年其实对我来说不太适应，当天晚上包括那去的第一个礼拜反正哭了很久，就一直掉眼泪。
这确实是真实存在的这个故事，但是过了一年两年三年之后呢？
我发现回家的之后，感觉有点交道不安，又想立刻回到学校去。
跟对我们在一起会感觉更加的快乐一些可能。
因为也可能已经逐步的适应了这个团体生活。
也感觉其实在每天的日常训练中，或者日常点滴中，大家变得更加这个融洽了。
也是潜于默化的做一些改变。
那对小张来说呢，你们有这种自己慢慢的从一个人有学会了跟大家一起有的一个过程吗？
我大部分的训练课都是一组的，就是会以一帮人的方式去进行。
然后有时候也会有，比如说放假，包括比如说行程错卡，你一个人去训练的时候。
对于我个人而言的话，一个人训练的时候是非常痛苦的。
我需要有一起训练的伙伴跟我一块，让我感受到那种活跃的气氛。
我是觉得没有同心者是一件比较痛苦的事情。
其实因为我们在游的过程当中，我们虽然很难去听到声音。
但是我们的眼睛还是能看到旁边的人的。
平时在训练当中，如果说能够看到顺歌，或者看到何俊义，他们在我旁边。
他们在那边拼的样子，其实还是能看得到的。
所以说在旁边看着他们一起，就会感觉团队的这种氛围。
就会有很强重连结的感觉，然后能够刺激我去跟他们共同向前。
我其实自己也有经历过一段时间，就是自己一个人训练。
就是你体会过一个人训练的那种孤独感之后，你再去对比大家一起训练。
你真的觉得时间都过得很快，就一堂课好像很快就过去了。
但一个人练你会觉得，哇，今天这堂课好漫长，好煎熬。
因为你只能听到自己的滑水声和呼吸声，你就会把这些情绪放大。
但是大家一起练的时候，你就会把注意力放在。
我要跟上前面的男生，我不能输给我边上跟我一组的队友。
就是大家会有一个非常良性的竞争，然后就会有很好的训练气氛。
那大家说这种感受也让我想到，其实我一个人。
我做播客的这个过程中，我也会觉得我自己在家看一本书。
或者想一个主题的时候，可能也不会想到那么多。
但跟我的播客搭到或者跟你们，跟我的嘉宾老师们坐在一起的时候。
我就突然有了很多问题，有了很多新的想法。
所以对话在某种程度上也是一个彼此激发。
因为有了你们，我才有了这些问题，这样的一个互动的过程吧？
其实跟你们这种大家彼此做伴一起训练激发出新的东西会有一点像。
所以我也想问顺哥，你在训练中，在生活中，是怎么样感受你身边人的状态的。
就包括你表示接纳的时候，你表示对他们的鼓励的时候。
其实都需要你提前先对他们有的状态，有一个判断，有一个感受。
所以你会非常注意去观察你的朋友，你的队友吗？
其实在这个环境里面，我们可以用我们自己的这种方式去很酷的一些方式。
让大家感受到我们自己的一些这种想法。
因为大家有相同的经历，这让我们在一些这种交流过程中，会更加的顺畅。
会更加的相互懂对方吧？
但其实你们的关系里，除了相互陪伴，相互鼓励，也有一些相互竞争的面向。
比如有谁赢，谁输，谁快，谁慢的这种比较。
那在这样一种比较和竞争的状态下，当你去安慰你的队友的时候，你会有什么不一样的心态。
或者说你自己交流的时候，特别注意的地方吗？
我觉得我们在赛场上是这个对手，平时生活中是这个队友。
这个队友的感情如何提升，就在赛场上大家相互的有多用力。
然后就是看谁把谁比下去。
你想以前不懂得为什么说我们要感谢对手。
但是对手可能是队友，可能是非常要好的朋友。
也可能是跨国界不认识的一些这种其他国家的一些运动员。
也是在一次次比赛完之后，大家在经过权力以赴的比赛。
以及漫长的这个备战，遇见很多伤病，解决伤病。
遇到很多问题，解决问题之后，在那个短短的几十秒中间。
大家把自己的最佳竞技状态拿出来了以后，在那个平台上。
大家其实会有一种心心相细的感觉，就应该在这个心心相细的感觉之后。
大家可能在赛场上的感情会越来越深刻。
因为你们一起经历过非常难忘的一些瞬间。
也都是在最后的这个决赛场上用尽了你自己的权力。
会让你感觉到它是一个你值得敬佩的人。
因为我觉得首先你得敬佩你自己，为什么？
因为你为了这件事情，你付出了巨大的一些努力和一些代价。
但有那么一个人，他可以跟你息鼓相当的在这个运动场竞争。
那么我想他一定也是付出了非常非常努力和非常非常多的代价。
他才能够站在这里跟你一起去竞争或者说是去共同。
去获得这么一枚金牌或者说理想中的目标。
我特别喜欢你都表达。
谢谢
对手也要彼此认可星星相机。
刚才我们聊天里谈到了很多汪顺。
作为大哥会照顾大家鼓励大家的一面。
我知道小叶其实在队里有的时候也是一个大姐的形象。
也会有一些年轻的队员找你倾诉。
然后找你询问一些他们的苦恼。
能给我们讲一讲这方面的故事吗？
好，大部分运动员可能是像我请教挖勇的技术。
我也会帮他们看一看挖勇的技术。
然后也会把我自己认为的一些小訣竅分享给他们。
也会有运动员可能比如说这个阶段遇到了很迷茫的一个时期。
然后也会就是过来问我一些经验吧？
然后我也会帮他们分析书里这个阶段的一些训练中的重点。
或者说每一堂课的重点。
就是会从我自己的经验当中去分享一些。
当然每个人不一样我也会跟他们说。
就是一定是以你自己的感受为主。
但是有一个前辈的经验作为指引还是非常重要的。
是不是
就像刚才顺哥说了我们经历过非常相似的这种人生的阶段。
然后也有过非常艰苦的训练包括一些伤病。
可能前辈的一些指导或者一些安慰会比别人更有意义。
没错，更有参考价值。
更有参考价值
那我们也想跟顺哥聊一个很近的一个时刻。
就是今年的6月16号在全国游泳冠军赛男子200米的个人混合泳的决赛里。
你以1分56秒16拿下了冠军。
这也是你在这个项目上第十次次夺冠。
第十三次联冠
非常非常的祝贺你。
谢谢
那看到成绩之后你心里冒出来的第一个想法。
第一个感受是怎样的呢？
首先我觉得是挺不可思议的。
因为在去年的全员会结束之后。
导游现在恢复我可能没有花多少时间。
从3月份那次比赛赛到这一次冠军赛。
其中是一共是11周。
然后比赛是第12周。
在这12周时间里可能用了非常多不同的一些方法。
才能够大家可能看到1分56秒16。
但是在这个背后其实靠我一个人是做不到的。
这个也就是我们前面说说的。
说要感谢你的团队。
所做出的一些巨大的一些这种帮助。
这个东西我觉得其实在我个人的话。
可能在身体上反而可能会更好一点。
但是在心理上的难关可能会更难一点。
特别是在你累的时候。
在你崩溃的时候
在你想要放弃的时候。
那可能就需要你的队友。
你的团队去帮你做出一些非常重要的一些托举。
这一次柯明外训张一祥他没有去吗？
我和何俊逸两个人是一块去。
然后小叶也没有去。
但是过程中我们其实不单单是训练。
然后更多的其实在训练之余。
我们去尝试了很多这种。
关于在心理恢复的一些种方式。
对 因为我们在大量的训练结束以后。
可能会对这个训练。
包括这用词失去
你本来想要去获得这么一个原始的一个动力。
跟一个我想要去突破的一个人为欲望。
如何去重塑这样子的一个心理建设。
跟一个这个方向
我们需要通过不一样的方法。
在这个时候
这是何俊逸他会在休息的时候。
带着我出去
拉着我出去
不应该说拉着我出去。
因为我已经不太愿意出去了。
很累了
他会拉着出去 他说走了。
好 去哪里去哪里。
我们去做一些不关于体育。
不关于游泳
不关于任何我们当下所做的事情。
我们抛开这些
我们去体验别的生活。
我们去看看风景
我们去喝个咖啡
或者说我们去尝一尝当地的一些茶。
然后感受一下当地的文化这样的方式。
方法
因为这样的方式
在大家可能最后看到了。
一分五十六秒一六的这么一个成绩。
当然在背后
当然何俊逸他现在。
当时我们的意思在困民所做的东西。
他只是一个缩影
有其他方面的一些。
比如像体能
像康复
像主教练
他们所做出的一些贡献。
结合起来
大家就看到这个
一个非常好的一个成绩的恢复。
对
你说的这个心理建设很有意思。
其实就是做一些游泳之外的事情。
跟比赛无关的事情。
是的
因为其实人就像一根弹簧。
你不能给自己完全完全压到底。
压到没有弹性了
对
我们需要通过一些其他的方式。
把这个弹簧
就恢复它的弹性
我们就做一些这种事情以外的。
所以说
以前觉得这个东西不太重要。
我可能在房间里好好休息就行了。
我可以第二天去面对这样的训练。
但是在体能休息之外。
更重要的其实是心理上的一个恢复。
对于你当下做的事情的一个期待值。
或者说对游泳池的这种。
想要在第二天训练的这种欲望值。
或者说是期待值
能不能恢复到你比较高的一个水质。
小河当时拉着顺歌。
出去干一些无关紧要的事的时候。
你是有一种什么样的感受。
你是也在学习怎么样获得。
这样一个放松的空间。
心理的空间吗？
对
因为我自己会觉得。
其实做运动员的时候。
特别是当你比较专注有目标。
包括那个目标
没那么容易达成的时候。
你的精神压力是会很大的。
其实我做运动员的时候。
我比顺歌会比较会自我放过自己。
对
所以就是
我觉得是恰恰有时候对我来说是确诊。
对他来说这是他需要去做的。
就是在线下之余
周末时间出去逛一逛。
哪怕是发发呆
哪怕是换一个环境。
我们再去聊游泳
在精神上绝对是一个很大的放松。
我一直觉得心情好。
对于你平时的工作状态。
还是最后取得的工作成果。
我们隐形当中都是有一定艺术的。
顺歌你已经是这次比赛里。
决赛组唯一的一个90后了。
在这样一个年龄阶段。
保持这样高的经济水准和竞争力。
你会觉得比小的时候。
比在前面几年更难吗？
我觉得一定会的
我觉得小叶肯定深有感触。
我觉得不单单这个东西是在训练上。
我觉得训练其实我们都OK。
比如说我今天要达到。
层次跟于远来相比。
我觉得可以比越来越快。
但是这个续航时间可能就不行了。
我可能以前我周一到周六。
我可以连续六天
高质量完成这个项目。
但是现在的话六天不可能了。
可能也就今天一天。
好了以后可能要花两三天。
三四天的时间恢复过来。
然后再完成一天
就是说在续航这件事上。
恢复这件事情上
跟以前相比的话是大大折扣的。
当然我有一段焦虑期。
我在想为什么我做不到像以前那样子了。
然后我就一直钻进了死胡同。
一直想要去寻找当时的当年的自己。
我想要一口节点六天。
但是时间告诉你
你再也回不去了
你只有往前看
当然这段时间我持续了非常非常久。
非常非常久
我一直在寻找解决的方法。
但最后最好的解决方法就是说。
接受当下
然后向前看
然后不再追求像原来那样子。
长续航的时间
我们现在就更多的可能会做一些。
当下我们就是把这个质量做高。
我们就单单一航客。
我们把质量做得非常高。
然后你要调整要恢复的时候。
就尽可能去调整
就像我们现在需要做的。
就是说你该训练的时候好好训练。
该吃饭的时候好好吃饭。
该休息就好好休息。
该放松的时候你就好好放松。
我们就把当下应该做的事情。
随着身体的一个状态。
然后去把它做好
再纠结过去
不再纠结是否有了动。
然后把以前那种因为游不动。
而有这种产生焦虑的心情。
给慢慢的消化掉
从而接受焦虑
接受当下的自己各种的一出现的。
一种身体状态
跟一个身体的一些不同的一些反应。
然后继续向节奏
那随着运动生涯变长。
运动的成就越来越高。
其实运动员总要面对这样一些客观的限制。
无论是体能上的 年龄上的。
我们面对越来越多现实的局限。
在这种情况下找到一种出路。
我也想听小叶给我们分享一下。
你在这方面的一些思考。
包括刚才小河提到的。
怎么给自己寻求一种心理空间。
一个放松的可能
你在这方面有什么想法吗？
我觉得顺哥前面简直说出了我的心声。
因为一名运动员
他其实巅峰的状态。
就是在十几岁的时候。
你的身体技能都是满血的状态。
然后那个时候你其实可以。
就是每一天冲强度。
睡一觉就恢复了
第二天也不会有什么疲劳的积累。
但其实在这个过程当中。
我们练了十几年
然后到了二十多岁的时候。
其实你身体的
不论是疲劳也好
以前透支的这些能量也好。
包括上面也好都在积累。
所以可能会在二十多岁的时候。
他就一下子爆发了。
这个时候其实最重要的是。
如何去养护好我们的零件。
可以说是
然后同时你又要去思考。
我怎么样能够再去提升自己。
能够在每天恢复过来的情况下。
第二天再去突破自己的。
今天这堂课的极限或者说一个目标。
我觉得这其实是非常难的。
所以我觉得就是到了这个年龄之后。
更多的是需要去思考。
需要去探索自己
就是去寻求一个
最适合自己的训练方式。
小叶也想聊到一个。
你很具体的一个比赛的时刻。
就是2024年的全国游泳冠军赛的时候。
你在女子200米挖泳里。
又出了2分22秒55。
拿到了冠军
也达标了巴黎奥运会。
那在这场比赛之前。
你刚刚经历了400米个人混合。
永无冤决赛的一个小小的打击。
甚至一度跟教练团队商量要不要退赛。
后来你还是站上了200米挖泳的赛场。
并且把这场比赛游了下来。
那现在回头看
你觉得那天把你拉回赛场的。
那种动力是什么呢？
是团队的一个鼓励吗？
还是现场的支持
还是心里的某个执念呢？
我觉得都有吧？
首先是我的团队
他们都非常的支持我。
然后也没有给我任何的压力。
因为当时我的不管是身体。
还是在精神层面
自信心都
都是一个受到打击。
非常糟糕的一个状态。
然后我的团队
包括我教练就说
你就先好好睡一觉。
然后第二天去游泳馆放松一下。
也没有跟我提后面比赛的事。
其实给了我很大的一个空间。
然后在这个过程中。
我又看到网上我的泳迷非常的支持我。
他们很关心我的身体。
然后也很希望我能够选上巴黎奥运会。
然后我就感受到这份爱吧？
我就觉得他们都这么信任我。
我怎么能够放弃自己呢？
所以我觉得我还是要站上这个赛场。
哪怕结果没有达到预期。
我觉得至少我要有勇气。
去面对这场比赛
无论是这件事情
还是你刚才提到了。
我们跟游泳相处了这么多年。
这么多年起起伏伏之后。
你觉得你跟游泳之间的关系。
发生过变化吗？
我觉得可能
就是在自己对游泳的这个项目的理解上。
会有产生过很多次的变化。
但是对于游泳的热爱是从来都没有变过的。
对
好的
我也想回到顺哥这边。
因为你也提到了一位。
对你来说很重要的恩师叫朱志根指导。
就在我们刚才提到的这个。
6月16号的全国游泳冠军赛上面。
你这次夺冠也第一时间感谢了朱指导。
说自己是软膜硬泡。
三顾毛炉
他已经退休了
他请回了团队
那在这样一个阶段继续往前走。
为什么还是需要一位。
很熟悉的这种老教练。
老朋友陪在身边呢？
首先这个确实
因为在去年结束之后。
我跟朱导也是
前年后说了不下十次吧？
我说能不能回来再带带我。
因为当时最早的时候。
我也不确定能不能自己。
再坚持下去练了
但是后来决定回到游泳池以后。
然后一直情绪后
我跟我们教练说了那么多次数。
他每次都说
也需要一些自己的时间。
跟一些生活
因为确实70岁了。
前面这些年一直
每天都是跟游泳池伪伴的。
也没有自己的一些。
这种生活陪陪家人之类的。
好不容易到这个时候了。
也需要一点自己时间。
所以我每次去跟他交流这个话题的时候。
他都没有答应
但是在最后一次的时候。
我跟他说
我说能不能再回来帮帮我。
然后我说我感觉你不在。
我说不太踏实
我其实没有抱太大希望了。
已经不抱希望了
他说他那天来了一句。
他说那怎么办
对对
他就这么一句话
我就瞬间一下子
我先生愣了几秒钟。
我发现
那是不是他还是愿意回来。
还是愿意就是说
陪着我后面再走几步。
然后回到他
非常熟悉的游泳池边。
所以在这样的契机下面。
后来又把诸刀请回来了。
为什么我说这个教练是。
觉得教练非常非常重要。
而且包括这次回来。
也不是像原来那样子。
就是说像原来那样带我来。
可能每天都在
或者怎么样不是了。
就是说
我们在比较关键的。
一些训练课的时候。
希望他能够到场
然后去稍微他就站在那。
他其实也不用多做什么？
我希望他能够在
训练场里
又在我们比赛的时候。
那为什么呢？
因为我觉得优秀的教练员。
为什么这么依赖他呢？
我相信我们在座的这四位。
我觉得都有一个
感同身受的一个感受。
就是优秀的教练员。
他首先是有一个
非常好的一个
这种训练的
对专业的一个知识。
这是首先的
其次如何成为一个。
优秀教练员
一个顶级的教练员。
他一定是一个
非常高明的一个心理老师。
就是在你遇到困难的时候。
在你比赛要退缩的时候。
他一句话就能够
给你十足的勇气跟底气。
让你去面对
所有世界上的一些强敌。
跟一些对手
这个我觉得是
作为顶级教练员
他的能力
那么诸导他就是这么一位人。
一位教练员
那包括小月之前的。
这个教练徐国毅徐之导。
他也是这样一位
一位非常优秀的教练员。
所以说我觉得优秀教练。
支持他首先具备的。
所以说为什么？
想要去把主导请回来。
那我想也是处于
后面如果参加一些国际比赛。
或者说参加一些大赛的时候。
他能够在我们心中。
成为我们心中
最有力的每一个后盾。
对
其实我跟顺哥一样。
因为我也是同样跟着。
朱之导就是算十五年吧？
就像顺哥说的
其实有时候
做运动员和教练之间的。
这种联系他不需要在平时。
有很多的一些操作。
或者说一些教导
到了年龄成为
大年龄运动员之后。
有时候最需要的就是教练在你。
面对压力
或者说面对对手
或者面对比赛的
这个未知的结果
当心理惶恐般的时候。
只需要教练的一句话。
所以朱导对我来说。
他其实就像一个精神图腾。
包括顺哥把他
叫回到泳池边上
他只要站在岸上
他就是一根定海神针。
有时候指挥官只需要。
身处战场之中
他不需要说话
我刚才听小河说了一个词很有意思。
叫大年龄运动员
我不知道是不是一个运动领域的。
或者运动队里的一个专有名次。
都是
所以你们在队里
会开关于年龄的玩笑吗？
一般都是开自己的玩笑。
因为经常就是在比赛的。
秩序册上面
全部都是00年
甚至10年后
就我一个久几年
我相信顺哥也深有体会。
大家都会说三行老人。
是这样子的
特别是在这一次
越是像艰苦的一些比赛项目。
像200滴400回。
1500米自由的这些项目上面。
从00后
现在已经慢慢顾虑到10后。
10后的占比也非常大。
所以说从对手
也是从80后90后00后。
现在到10后了
跨幅已经跨到40年了。
我之前看体育比赛的时候。
还在想
当我们看类似三国演艺。
这种古装剧的时候。
当你看到所谓老将出场。
指的是六七十岁的老将。
而你在看比赛的时候。
老将指的是90后。
是的 其实为什么？
从以前的我们钢进队。
是小运动员的时候。
那时候的大运动员。
基本上就20出头。
都退一了
然后都踏上新的工作岗位。
然后开始了第二职业了。
为什么现在游泳运动员。
越来越多的年纪
会越来越大
能够练到20大级3只出头。
我现在其实背后
也是因为我们团队。
越来越细致化了
也是团队的力量
让大家做自己非常擅长的事情。
从而让我们的运动寿命。
运动生涯越来越吵了。
以前的话
我们一个教练员
又要当爹 又要当妈 又要当保姆。
又要管他自己的训练的事情。
然后体能的事情
他要一手抓
比如说我们出去外训的时候。
他又要当司机
又要当厨师
又要当翻译
可能是
又要当他自己本职的教练。
就一个人当五六个人在用。
可以做是可以做
但是他做的
没有像原来那么？
大家所擅长的那么精细。
我们现在有非常多。
专业的人去做专业的事情。
所以说让我们现在。
能够感受到大家的运动寿命。
越来越长了
现在其实20多的运动员。
其实非常非常多
大家都觉得
以前觉得20多
已经是二老运动员了。
我们要退役
我们要去寻找新的生活方式了。
但现在的话
大家都感觉20多。
才可能刚刚开始
才可能发育完你的。
这种胜利状态
然后能够在这个项目上。
更进一步
因为游泳相对来
其他的项目来说
他算是一个体能项目。
而且又属于一个青少年项目。
不像其他的项目
他可能成人项目
因为游泳相对来说。
12、13、45岁。
就已经出成绩的非常多。
现在小叶子就是
16岁已经在奥运之巅了。
对
所以说
他是一个青少年项目。
而且如何把你在
青少年项目
然后又是体能项目的情况下。
你一直维持到3、3几岁。
这个我觉得是一团队的力量。
包括何俊英
也是97年的运动员。
到现在也已经是29岁了。
像张静翔是01年的。
到现在也是25岁了。
对
所以说我觉得
现在大家的运动寿命。
越来越长
还是得以于我们
有非常好的这种团队。
去帮助我们
在运动的道路上
越走越远
其实汪顺也经历了一段时间。
我不去游泳
我去做其他的事情。
然后又重回泳池的这样一个经历。
我记得是在
2025年全运会之后。
给自己放了一个
四个月的假期
然后也去爬山
去旅行
唯独不游泳
然后最后发现
这个状态
这个时间的生活
好像还不太适合自己。
然后又重新回到了泳池。
所以在那段时间里。
你跟自己发生了
怎样的对话呢？
这也是我
第一次下定决心
离开泳池
确实那段时间
那次比赛对我来说。
我以为是最后一次了。
特别是在
去年全运会的
两万云混合
决赛结束之后
我其实在后台
在准备活动的地方。
我是痛哭流涕的
别人可能不理解
你这个金牌对你来说。
很容易
但是对我来说
我以为我当时
那是我最后一次
去一万两万云混合用了。
我可能我这辈子
再也不会去我这个下午了。
我可能是对我自己的。
职业生涯
或者说是对于
两万云混合用的
这么一个方法
但是结束之后
离开了一段时间
我发现做很多事情。
当然非常开心
但这个开心
不足以让我踏实
我觉得还是回到游泳池。
虽然枯燥
但是能够让我感受到。
我是活着的
不管是否能够做到什么程度。
或者是多少时间
但起码当下
我觉得是让我有这种。
存在的最意义的感受吧？
对
所以其实即使回到游泳。
这件事情中间
也是回到队友中间。
是的 因为这个环境。
确实很让人割舍不开。
OK
队友之间的影响
可能有的时候
并不是说一句话
或者一次非常具体的陪伴。
可能只是看见对方。
完成了一次冲刺
一次比赛
自己的这种
身体力的某一部分。
也会被重新点燃
我记得小叶在
2013年全云汇的时候。
赛前就是非常紧张。
那天正好汪顺
也比400混在你前面。
然后你在休息的时候。
看完了他的比赛
在最后50米他反超。
拿到了第一
你说自己
被他的一种斗志所点燃了。
充满了力量
所以那个瞬间
你觉得自己发生了什么？
是看到队友游得很好。
自己觉得我也可以吗？
是当时其实
那个阶段
可能是我状态
比较低迷的一个阶段。
然后比赛前我就非常紧张。
其实当时紧张到
我都在发抖
然后400混
又是一个
特别艰苦的项目
我就很害怕自己
就是又会出现
以前那种错误
可能在比赛中
就没有办法坚持下来。
就是一直力顶不住。
然后很巧的是
我正好在去简陆前。
我还能看一下
顺歌的决赛
然后当时就看到
他最后50米
瞬间反超对手
就是那种斗志
他会一下子
就像点燃我身体里的。
某一种能量一样
就是被击中了
瞬间我就感觉
热血沸腾
就是把那种紧张
一下子就转化成了。
一种能量
一种勇气
对
是的 因为
大家平时在交流中。
也会交流的
特别是小叶当时
2013年400米混合用。
因为我是当时的那天。
第一天第一项
当时我教练说
开个好头
当时我没有什么概念。
但是我现在一点一点。
自己有体会了
其实队友在赛阳上去获胜。
去游得好成绩
其实是特别能给别人力量。
我想这个用个词
就是试起
试起会高涨
对
同样这个东西
也是用在我身上
看到这个
大家包括小叶
在这个奥运会的舞台上。
世界舞台上去打博士记录。
然后我的金牌的时候。
依然会给我们非常多的。
一些动力跟感动
包括和军艺也是
当时在2021年。
冬季奥运会的时候。
结束完我自己的这个比赛。
他也是
他说
孙哥 你的比赛结束了。
我说
我说两个月后是这个全运会。
我说那时候
你的比赛才开始
对 就大家其实
虽然是不同的这个。
这个舞台
或者不同的赛场去。
整体多赢
但是我觉得
给大家彼此的这种力量。
我觉得是
没有减少的反而会更多。
然后对着这个目标。
会更加的坚定
会更加的清晰
小和 我记得你也说过。
汪顺给人的感觉
是不会被打败的
这样一种感觉
那当他练到
累了顶不住的时候。
你是不是会
抓住机会来超上一板。
对你来说
你们有这种
按按较劲的时候吗？
对
哪怕你看
放在现在的比赛当中。
大家都觉得
在谎和勇这个项目。
或者说
迪亚瓦斯任何一个项目。
比孙哥款式
一件比较难做到的事情。
对于我来说
我在训练的时候
我喜欢挑战
而他的训练能力
就是非常的强
所以对我来说
当他每次状态不好。
或者感觉累的时候。
我要做的第一件事。
肯定是先是打败他。
然后同时
我觉得这也是一种。
共同进步
因为我会挑衅他
让大家把这个世纪提起来。
然后就更好的去完成。
这堂课
比如说像今天
上午打腿训练
他虽然现在没有跟我在边上。
一块打腿了
但是他通过他的
在岸上的耳脉传递。
告诉边上的小队员。
要干掉我
然后今天早上
其实打得还挺不错的。
腿的成绩
也是打出我这些年。
一个比较好的成绩。
大家在这样的情况下。
每人相互竞争
这也是他的风格
其实
因为我们除了
水上训练
我们还有路上训练。
然后在我们路上
很多力量训练当中。
我们就其实
大家练着练着
不自觉的
就会去比较
就比如说
我加重一点
我再加重一点
或者我多做两个
就是用比较
会也是能激发斗职。
激发自己潜力的
我觉得
所以你们路上训练。
一般都训练什么呢？
我们路上有
很多方面的训练
其中就是会有一些。
比如说
爆发力的训练
然后还会有一些
比如说像
深蹲
或者说
握腿之类的力量训练。
然后就这些训练当中。
都会有重量上的比较。
相比水下的训练
你觉得陆地的训练。
有什么你特别喜欢。
或者特别不喜欢的项目吗？
他特别喜欢
腿部的训练
为什么？
因为他是蹲得最重的。
比如说像这种
前蹲
然后跟后蹲
会比我们几个
蹲得自主多
然后蹲得重量大
所以说他会
相比来说
在这方面
这时候的时候
会有不一样的感受。
所以说在路上训练。
其实我也在
暗角级
但确实
到重量了
该起不来还是起不来。
这心有余力不足
所以有什么？
你们特别不爱做的吗？
比如你特别不爱做什么？
我特别不爱做
深蹲
因为蹲不过他们
小和呢？
我爱做
所以我能比得过别人的。
就是我们力量训练。
跟水里面游泳的训练区别。
就是你在路上训练。
跟别人比较的时候。
你可以一边做
一边喷垃圾话
水里面不可以
小叶也在点头
你也有同感吗？
那我可能跟他们不太一样。
因为我比较擅长
就是心肺的训练
以及就是核心的训练。
但是我觉得对于
短距离运动员来说。
力量训练是必不可少的。
一部分
对
然后我觉得力量训练。
也能够很好的然之。
因为在
经历了力量训练之后。
你的身体会在24小时。
都持续保持一个
然之的状态
对
所以我觉得对于
需要增几乎的然之的。
朋友们来说
力量训练还是
很好的一个选择
对
你也会跟你的队友。
按较劲
比如谁多做了一个。
谁多跑了一点吗？
我感觉路上训练我还好。
水上训练我们
女运动员之间
也会按较劲
看着油
我要比你流得快
倒杯要比你扫
就是会这样
这样挺好的
日常的训练里
也有一种比赛的气氛在。
对
是 良性竞争
虽然这些微小的竞争。
每天都在发生
就比如蹲腿身
谁多蹲了一个
谁蹲的重一点
打腿是更快一点
但是不是这种
玩校班的心态
训练时候的心态
跟大赛中还是
大家站在
同一个赛场上的时候。
还是非常不一样的呢？
是的
因为训练是大家
我们其实更多的
把一些
模拟性的比赛
融到了平时的训练中。
就像为什么？
我们会有
这些高强度的模拟训练。
大家需要去相互的一些股进。
然后模拟当下的一个。
氛围
其实说白了
就是我们排解
当时比赛的时候
会带来一些焦虑感。
跟一些这种紧张感。
如果你在评训训练中。
我们都能够做到99%。
或者说是100%的时候。
或者甚至超越她的时候。
当我们在面对比赛的时候。
一定是会更加的从容。
更加的自信一些
对
因为你之前也表达过。
对于家这项运动
还是很有兴趣的
那你觉得
于家这项运动
吸引你的地方是什么呢？
是比如帮助身体打开。
或恢复
或者是说跟自己
状态重新连接的一种方式。
其实我觉得
以前我对于家没什么干颜。
突然在今年的时候。
有一次偶然机会
被一位领入人带入了。
这个体验了一次
我感觉跟我平时接触的。
不太一样
因为我们进一步要快。
但是于家是让你如何慢下来。
这个我觉得是非常重要。
因为快
我觉得很多人都能做得到。
但是慢
它是需要去锻炼的。
需要去锻炼的
所以说
这给了我不一样的一些。
这种在对运动上
对这种人生态度上的一些。
不同的一些这种学习。
以及它对自己
甚至一个控制力
以及一些柔韧性
协调性
它提出了非常高的要求。
然后也从中
感受到了不一样的一种状态。
然后和自信
因为它更多的是一个向内的。
跟一个自己去比较。
自己去珍藏自己的那种一个过程。
那你刚才也提到了。
运动员
是要有心理空间的一个打开。
或许于家也可以在这方面帮到吗？
因为之前你总说
你会给别人带去快乐。
带去鼓励
带去安慰
但小和之前说过一句话。
他说你总是会忘了让自己开心。
你知道这个评价吗？
这个对他也跟我说过。
但是这个老忘记了。
所以小和为什么会这样讲呢？
是觉得他太照顾别人。
顾及别人太多吗？
对
包括到后面
随着训练
可能年龄增长慢慢成为。
对里面年龄比较大的运动员之后。
他不止于对自己教练组的运动员。
在对整个浙江队
包括一些小运动员。
到面临一些挫折
包括他们脸上写满了。
对训练的压力的那些焦虑的时候。
训练也会去逗一逗他们。
帮助他们有一些放松。
但是就是比如说
在一些大赛之前
长期枯燥的训练
谁都会陷入一个很疲惫的状态。
哪怕他水平更高
哪怕他可能精力更好。
他也会很疲惫
但是有时候在运动队。
你又会忍不住的去帮助一些小队员。
希望把自己的一些经验或者教训。
分享给别人
但同时其实
帮助别人解决困扰的同时。
消耗的也是自己的能量。
大家也都知道
顺个在这方面
他很热心
所以他有时候也会把自己搞得很累。
他有时候会有自己沉默发呆的时候。
对于我来说
我觉得有时候
他哪怕是年龄最大的。
会有需要鼓励的地方。
我觉得这事情
其实大家都是相互的。
在我可能去帮助别人的同时。
大家可能也会来帮助我。
就像何俊一张一张。
还有包括小叶
我们其实在一起的时候。
大家其实都是相互的。
比如说今天他状态。
可能低迷一点的时候。
我们大家可能会多鼓励鼓励他。
多安慰他
甚至有时候多刺激刺激他。
也会有
同样反过来的时候。
在我个人比较累的时候。
能量比较低的时候。
他们会用他们的方式方法。
去帮我走出当时的一个。
比较低迷的一个环境。
或者说比较压力比较大的环境。
然后继续共同向前。
我觉得队友和朋友。
还有教练这个团队里。
我们觉得是一个
非常好倾诉的这么一个对象。
你可以对他说
你当下很不好的感受。
说发现你的情绪
但这东西都是相互的。
过了之后
大家谁都不会记得。
大家只会记得
在那个瞬间的时候。
是你的朋友 你的队友。
一起共度了那个难关。
我其实经常有
就是一直以来
我都觉得有被照顾到。
不单单举现一些某件事情。
就是他是很长的一个时间。
跨度
就在每天的日常
不管是训练
还是生活当中
其实都会有
这种很温暖的感觉。
每次就是
感受到这种感觉的时候。
你就会想
我反过去
也给顺格一点关心。
或者给顺格一点
怎么说呢？
一点贡献我的力量。
有时候都用他自己的方式。
方法
然后也会来问一下。
比如说像
我们更多的
可能都是关心为主。
关心可能更多一点。
然后一起会在
比如说可能看
晚上可能吃的比较少。
或者说是出去带个水果。
用这样的方式
可能会多一点
对 大家相互的
就是游泳这项运动。
像你们刚才说
在路上训练的时候。
大家就可以说一些垃圾话。
可能在水里的时候。
大家相对来说
还是比较安静的
然后它是一个
你需要跟自己相处。
面对自身的一个运动。
尤其是在水下
一个非常寂静的
干净的一个空间里的时候。
但回到岸上的时候。
身边又围满了队友。
就是两种空间的对比。
感受的对比
是特别不一样的
所以你们在水里游泳的时候。
那种孤独和安静
到底是怎样一种感受呢？
能跟我分享一下吗？
怎么形容游泳这个项目呢？
就以前
我觉得小时候
我想立马把这个量游完。
游到边以后
开始跟队友聊天
就恨不得
就是一下子
不要有这个训练量。
或者怎么样
就一直都站在那边说话。
这是小时候对游的感觉。
然后你说
要大家怎么去理解。
这个比较枯燥的游泳的感受。
就比如说
我们在做一件事情的时候。
我明明很想去交流。
做一些事情
但是你不能交流
你的嘴巴是被交在着风着的。
可能这个形容可能会。
会让大家有一些共鸣吧？
就是
小河有什么想分享的吗？
就是水下运动对你来说。
是一项比较孤独的运动吗？
水下运动对外
因为我很喜欢说话。
所以有时候
就像盛东说的
在小时候
你在水里游的时候。
你BUFF得赶快到边。
然后跟身边的训练伙伴一起去讲。
就是你在游的时候。
脑子里想的东西去分享。
然后随着慢慢的
就是对这个项目的专注度。
越来越高了之后
有时候我最想说的就是。
有一部电影不是那么F1吗？
它最后结尾的时候。
就是主角进入了一个。
所谓的心流的状态。
到后面
我觉得训练最好的状态就是。
进入到类似有一个心流。
就是你完全专注于。
自己在水里面的
每一下滑水
每一下动作
同样进入那种状态之后。
一堂比有两个小时的课。
可能在你眼中
一眨眼就过去了
一天也是
然后作为运动员
我觉得进入一个那样的状态之后。
持续性的能保持下去。
对我来说是一种幸福。
到后面有时候的沮丧。
也是源于就是你没有办法。
再去进入到那种
让自己很专注的状态之后。
我觉得就可能就需要休息。
小张呢？
来跟我们分享一下。
你游泳的时候都在想些什么？
其实我游起来
因为我们游泳池的。
它的底都是一样的。
就是你经常游着游着。
你就会不知道自己游了多久。
不知道自己游了几圈。
就是会有这种感觉。
但是呢？
你游一个转头
我们换气的时候
会看到旁边有
队友在旁边
其实抛开
听不到以外
就你能看到之后
其实是会一定程度上。
缓解你的那种孤独的感觉。
就是大家冰牌在游的时候。
然后看到他们
就还是能有一些缓解。
小叶有什么跟我们分享的吗？
你觉得游泳是一项。
很孤独的项目吗？
可能大家会理解
游泳是一项孤独的项目。
因为你游的过程当中。
你是没有办法和别人交流的。
特别是游长距离
比如说一个1500米左右。
我自己的方法就是。
脑袋里不停地唱不同的歌。
就是去缓解这种
就是怎么说
枯燥法卫的感受
但是确实像小张刚说的。
你游的时候看到你身边的队友。
他可能和你一样
今天在为自己的
这堂课的目标而奋斗的时候。
你就觉得自己不孤独了。
就大家都在拼搏
然后有那么多队友。
陪着你一起
就是那个氛围
他真的会让你觉得。
这个时间在不知不觉中。
就过去了
所以你们还记得
自己最开始下水的时候。
是怎么样的吗？
就是你们是
天赋是体现在一开始下水。
我就很喜欢这个运动。
我就发现我很擅长游泳。
会有这样一个天赋炸线的时刻吗？
我觉得是这样子的。
因为做任何事情
我觉得像金字塔
首先最下面那一层。
一定是天赋
你如果没有一定天赋。
没有一定的热爱
我觉得你是
做不了这件事情的。
我觉得不单单是游泳。
不单单是体育
任何行业 任何事情。
一定是的
但是在天赋的这一层。
大基础下面
大家可以通过努力。
把自己带到更高的。
这么一个层次
你可以到你想要的层次。
你付出的汗水
一定跟你的结果
一心一意是成正比的。
但是在这个上面
还有一层运气
你可能需要一个
健康的身体
可能在某个阶段里面。
你的对手
可能因为一些意外。
导致手伤
然后你就变成了
当时这个项目里面。
最强的那个人了
那可能是需要一些运气。
或者说是对手
因为这两天来到这里。
对手水渡不服
然后因为拉肚子了。
这个也是会在比赛中。
会经常发生的一件事情。
在这个上面
这是第三层
还有一层就是
我们大家所说的
一个心理状态
如何去构建自己一个。
非常强大的
这么一个心理状态。
我们就像前面说的。
一个是运动员自身本身。
在平时所带来的训练。
所带来的一个自信。
以及教练最后
对你的鼓励跟肯定以外的。
这么一个东西
因为在最后顶尖的。
这个赛场上的时候。
大家八个运动员
每个运动员
都是会有多惯的
这个实力跟可能的。
如果我们在这个状态下面。
有些运动员
因为对自己的这个。
不自信往后退了一步。
有些运动员
他对自己非常的自信。
或者说教练员
或者团队帮助他了。
建立了更多的自信。
他往前进了一步
在同样的这种能力下面。
那这样子就差了三步了。
那最后这个运动员。
即便我们实力差不多。
或者比你弱一点
他都能够区区的
最后这么一位冠军。
所以说我们在这样子。
一个金字塔的一个框架下面。
总天赋努力
然后再是运气
然后在心里
这么四部分加在一起。
构成了我们的这个运动员。
这么一个最后的一个。
呈现的一个东西吧？
那今天我们其实聊的很多。
是大家作为队友的一个陪伴。
以及教练团队
对我们这样一个重要的意义。
是在聊我们身边的人。
我也想知道在你们最开始。
接触这项运动的时候。
有没有一个人
让你觉得是非常重要的。
他可以是你们的父母。
或者说你们的启蒙教练。
或者说儿时的某一个朋友。
让你在最开始接触游泳的时候。
觉得他很有意思
或者我愿意从事这项运动。
所以你们小的时候有这样一个。
儿时的所谓的精神上的队友吗？
我觉得对于我来说的话。
启蒙教练非常重要。
因为他是发掘了你这项。
天赋的这么一个人。
他把你带入了
这个行业的这么一个。
契机的这么一个人。
让你有机会在后面的。
这个舞台上去展现自己。
这是肯定的
以及在小的时候
我觉得能够坚持下来。
到现在更多的
我觉得不是靠我自己。
靠的是父母
因为小孩子他没有很多的长性。
比如说我今天
第一天 第二天我有兴趣想去。
第三天的时候我累了。
我说我不想去了
我想休息
我想要吃好吃的
我想要去做其他事情。
我不想再那个了
因为小孩子的长性比较差。
他只有兴趣
但这时候他需要父母的去坚持。
他父母给你带过去。
那这时候你会有抵触情绪。
而且遇到这种
官风下雨
放寒暑假的时候
你的抵触性会更大。
那你的父母怎么如何帮你去。
做好心理工作
这一关或者说带着你去。
365天
你看着别的小朋友。
周末出去去那里那里旅游了。
那个喊家暑假去那里那里旅游了。
周末的时候去那里那里玩了。
但是你没有
我们那所有的周末。
所有的喊家
其实说白了都是在拥管度过的。
但是反过头来
我们再看看值不值得。
我们虽然在
这些年失去了一些这种。
结架人的一些自由。
但是我们通过
大家相互的
在团队里中
一些相互的业努力跟一些努力。
我们其实获得东西。
非常非常多
但是获得东西
我觉得不一定指的是。
金牌也好
我的第一名也好
还是说我们在这个过程中。
我们学会了相互鼓励。
我们学会了相互学习。
我们学会了相互
在对手中
他们的一些
成功的一些方式的一些。
这种精神的一些力量。
这个东西是
我觉得失去一些
这种结架热的同时。
获得非常宝贵的一些财富。
我觉得刚刚顺哥
首先提到的父母
我觉得其实这个我感触。
还是比较大的
因为包括最早就是我父母。
他们希望我去游泳。
然后把我送到了
以前试的体校里面去学习。
然后在后来的很长的一段时间里面。
有过几次
其实我是想要放弃的。
但是在我放弃的时候。
我父母他们就会说。
你既然已经做了这个事情了。
就还是要去把它坚持了。
然后把它做好
所以我觉得其实
我能够一直游到今天。
完完全全也少不开。
我父母对我的鼓励。
跟他们的给我的一些。
心理上的安慰吧？
所以说家庭是最小的。
这个团队单位
感受到了
对我来说的话
小的时候学游泳
首先我最感谢的一个人。
应该是我的伯乐
就是我的幼儿园班主任。
因为他是从我平时。
在学校的一些表现。
就是发现我性格中。
有非常不服输非常坚韧的一部分。
然后他就建议我去学游泳。
然后确实我的琴墨教练看了之后。
也觉得我是挺有天赋的。
就走上了这条道路。
然后我觉得在刚开始。
学游泳的过程当中。
其实当时身边的小伙伴。
对我来说帮助真的非常大。
因为那个时候
我父母其实不会给我。
就是在成绩上有什么要求。
然后每天我最快乐的事情。
就是下了学之后
赶紧去游泳馆
然后跟小伙伴们
会在训练前
先一起玩一些游戏之类的。
然后再一起训练
我会觉得那个氛围就是。
特别开心
对
那刚才顺哥其实提到了两次。
包括最开始提到了。
跟对手之间的这种心心相惜。
然后刚才其实也提到了。
这种高水平运动员之间。
其实有一种彼此珍惜的。
这样一种感觉
大家不光是对手
也是某种程度上的灵魂朋友。
因为你知道
他也经历了这些事情。
他也面对跟你一样的挑战。
我特别想听四位展开讲讲。
就是你们是怎么样看待。
这种职业生涯中
贯穿始终的竞争的。
你们怎么去面对自己的对手。
或者有的时候
可能是一个心魔
可能是我怎么就是在某一次比赛中。
在某个项目中
好像就是游不过他。
所以你们怎么看待这样的竞争。
以及跟对手之间的这种。
到最后是高手之间。
心心相惜的这种感受呢？
其实在比赛的过程中。
我们都会有输赢
都会有输赢
我们也是在
从市里面到省里
到全国到亚洲
最后到世界
在不同阶段
我们都会遇到不同的对手。
在我们刚开始
职业生涯的时候
在国际上
会有一些其他一些。
国家的一些地区的一些。
非常优秀的选手
跟你差不多年纪的。
然后水平也差不多的。
我们成这些对手
叫做一辈子的对手。
因为他会跟你在国际舞台上。
竞争一辈子直到你退役。
而且他们的年龄成长状态。
然后以及他们的这种训练的这种。
对自己的这种恢复。
我们其实都是在处于。
一个差不多的一个阶段。
所以我想在
如果想成为一个优秀运动员。
在这条道路上面
首先要做的其实说白了。
就是在这样子
差不多的这种环境里面。
去一点一点拼出来。
竞争出来
只有在这样的情况下面。
你走到最后的时候。
你才会有更多的一些。
这种经验
更多的一些任行
然后以及对胜利的一种。
必胜的一些决心
这个我是觉得
作为可能在最后国际舞台上。
能够再见的时候
这些对手的一些
这种最基础的一些东西。
当然在这些过程中。
为什么回答都最后会心情相惜。
因为大家都会遇到。
很大的困难
比如说在这次比赛中。
我赢了你
或者是你赢了我
都会不服输
你凭什么赢我
对
那我回去要找到问题。
然后下一次我们再接着干过。
这样子的一种心态。
跟一种方法促使着你。
一次一次又一次一次一次的去。
不断挑战自己
然后从而最后去
或者说是去战胜
你想要战胜的对手。
最后这样的一个结果。
这也是一个非常非常。
重要的一个动力来源。
所以当你听说
你这种所谓一辈子的对手。
一辈子的敌人
比如他遭遇了伤病。
或者说他在某次比赛的时候。
不是很幸运
比如水土不服啊？
拉肚子了
你是不是也会有内心的波动。
就是说那是我这次运气好。
或者说很为他觉得晚息。
我觉得会非常非常的遗憾。
因为每次比赛
其实我们大家都是充分的去准备。
然后全力以赴的去面对。
遇到这样的情况
首先是非常非常遗憾。
也替他
就是说如果有这样的情况发生。
也是会替对手感到非常的晚息。
就像有一次我记得是。
对我来说2015年那时候。
他因为走步骑自行车摔伤以后。
没有办法到当时的那个比赛去参加。
其实确实非常遗憾。
因为那一年我做了很多准备。
然后我希望能够在这次比赛上。
去展现自己的成绩。
然后去看看能不能去。
跟他有一拼之力
但是因为他一些赛前的一些原因。
导致没有办法来参赛。
就会感觉一个是特别可惜。
一个也是希望他能够早点康复。
当时就像一个心理波动。
跟一个心理想法就是说是。
我可能没有顺歌那么深刻的感触。
但是有一点就是
就一步一步从一个比如说。
刚获得这个赛事标准。
然后再到慢慢进步到半决赛。
到进步到决赛
再到后面长达好多年当中。
在决赛当中碰到的对手。
都是同一批人的时候。
在其实在比赛比完之后。
就是会有那些星星相细。
不打不相识
我觉得我对于对手的看法。
可能更多的
就在于他像一个
一面镜子一样
他能够看出来
我是否能有更好的表现。
我是否在过去的时间里面。
有没有去更努力的训练。
去更加的提高自己。
所以说在赛场上
如果说能够战胜别人。
包括能够击败一些对手。
或者曾经输过的对手。
我创造出了更好的自己。
我击败了他们
就也是对我的一种坑底。
我觉得对手的存在。
其实对我个人的成长是。
非常有帮助的
互相促进的
很良性的竞争
我记得有一个阶段。
当时挺早的哪一年。
我具体哪一年
我也忘了
比了一场短持的市井赛。
然后我200魂和400魂。
都输给同一个对手。
我就特别痛恨
拿第二名的感受
下一个阶段的训练。
我每一天脑子里都把那个对手。
当成我的目标
拼命在练
我相信就是
比如说这次比赛我赢了。
可能输给我的那个对手。
也会把我当成他的目标。
我觉得这是很好的一种。
良性的竞争
然后我们也会去学习。
对手身上的一些优点。
甚至是学习他们的。
一些技术或者战术。
对
其实一个团队的气质。
不是由一个人决定的吗？
而是每个人都把自己的。
一部分性格的特质。
或者人的特质放进来。
有的人带来的可能是激情。
有的人给团队
带来的可能是安静和专注。
或者热爱和坚韧
汪顺曾经提到过小和。
是一个很有激情的人。
能够在沉闷 枯燥的训练里。
带来调味剂
小张是一个默默努力。
学霸型的运动员
小叶的身上
则有非常强的热爱和坚韧。
你们三个人是怎么样。
看待汪顺的这样一个评价的。
有什么想要回应的吗？
我觉得得到顺歌
给我激情两个字
作为我的形容
对我来说是一种认可。
因为我是一个很害怕无聊的人。
同时我也觉得
因为我们是激情的运动。
有用这项运动它充满了动。
它可能相比其他运动。
它没有一种对抗
所以它像田径
就是你在自己的拥道里面。
精神着自己的
怎么说的一种激情。
所以说在一个组的训练当中。
对我来说
如果太安静的话
我接受不了这样的氛围。
我会想着用自己去调动它们。
如果其他人会跟着我。
或者说愿意来跟我。
做比较来比的话
在训练当中
就有一个比赛的这种氛围。
对我来说是一件很高兴的事情。
也会让我更投入
小张为什么是一个。
学霸型的运动员
我觉得可能大部分时候。
我不会去主动的
表达太多的一些内容。
但是因为我们大家团队里面。
这么多人
我们都有像性格不同。
我们大家个性不相同的人。
但是我们大家融合在了一个团队。
所以有些时候
我觉得我对于我自己来说。
虽然可能表达的不是那么多。
但是我也就是很开心。
能有它们能够给我带来。
不一样的这种元素。
包括像刚顺哥说的。
像何俊逸他有些时候。
他又会非常活泼的来。
自己我们或者之类的时候。
我就会感觉其实也很好。
小叶为什么是那个。
以热爱和坚韧注称的人。
感谢顺哥的肯定
我觉得他对我们每个人。
真的都很了解
就是很精准
真的很精准
不愧是这么多年
培养出来的默契
去年其实大家看到了。
顺哥和甲龄拍的广告。
那今年是你们四个。
在一起拍这个广告。
顺哥有什么不一样的感觉。
我觉得这两年都是。
对我来说非常美好的回忆。
都有不同形式的一些改变。
无论是队友还是跟甲龄。
老师的一些
一起运动的一些场景。
都是非常令人难忘的。
每个瞬间
相比之下
我觉得这个队友的话。
肯定会更加了解一点。
就像张翔一样
平时为什么说他学挖型的。
他会有时候在训练中。
他会跟你分析一些东西。
比如说像我们在练习。
一些这种力量训练。
以及一些对手的一些这种数据。
然后包括一些成绩的时候。
他会用一些他独特的一些。
比较有思维的一些东西。
去做一些进击
然后有感觉
这个逻辑是对的
这样的方式方法
对
那我也想问问另外三位。
就是小叶 小张和小和。
你们今年拍摄拍下来。
会觉得好玩吗？
感受怎么样
挺好玩的
我觉得挺好玩的
然后我确实是没有想到。
拍摄的过程还是蛮累的。
对
就是感觉
很真实
然后综合了
可能一周的新链量吧？
真的吗？
真的真的
我们那天拉引体
可能就有拉了有七八十个。
我的天
错过了
今年没有去围观你们。
拉引体向上
对
很还原就是男生之间。
这种互相较劲
互相PK的那种场面。
对
小张小和呢？
你们觉得怎么样
对我来说
拍摄前
孙哥就跟我说
他说路拉门的拍摄。
就是完全呈现
我们平时的训练课就好。
我就会觉得确实很累。
但是拍得很开心
它更像是一堂快乐的体能课。
而且这个体能课
它非常的真实
它非常的累
但是时间同样过得也非常的快。
进入心流状态了
最后总结就是
非常开心
非常快乐
我觉得很开心
因为我们平时本身。
就是大家在一起的队友。
所以说这个拍摄更像是。
就是记录
大家的真实的训练的过程一样。
完全不会有不一样的感觉。
就感觉很顺其自然。
好像也像
很多都是我们日常当中。
会发生的事情
把它记录了下来一样。
就感觉特别的有意思。
一模一样的
大家其实就是
平时训练中怎么样。
然后那天其实也就怎么样。
然后那天其实让我。
印象非常深刻
就是拉引体
拉引体那么一瞬间说。
大家要在上面
稍微保持一下子
那一瞬间
我的心里话
我是全力以赴了
我看到他们
也是全力以赴在发抖。
然后下来以后
他们说
怎么你还顶在那边。
你为什么不赶紧下来。
然后导致大家其实都在。
像自己的最极限去坚持。
所以说
虽然可能只是一个拍摄。
但是大家其实在那个过程中。
大家其实还是叫双劲了。
夏天确实是一个
很适合热汗运动的季节。
很多人也会约朋友。
一起去运动
那比起这个运动的结果。
或者竞赛的结果
其实我们在运动中。
在团队里
获得一个好感受
是更重要的
之前顺歌也去参加过。
Lemon夏日乐挑战活动的现场。
你在现场看到了什么？
你在现场有什么样的感受。
作为一个专业的运动员。
去参加一个普通人。
一个竞技的比赛
我觉得其实去年的。
这个成都的这个夏日乐挑战。
对我来说是一个非常难忘的。
这么一个活动
他跟我以前
参加过的一些运动会也好。
然后一些活动也好。
他是一个比较
特别独立的什么？
一个存在的一个
一个形式跟方式
他让我很自在
为什么用自在这个词呢？
因为
首先我是一个运动员嘛？
然后他用我非常熟悉的方式。
在一个不太那么严肃的。
这么一个场合的一个。
这样的方式去运动。
去活动
去享受运动这个魅力。
特别就是在夏天
我们大家这个
对于运动这个热情。
都会更加的高涨
以及用一个这个团队的方式。
去完成一些
比较吸引的一些项目。
这个我觉得是对于。
这个难忘回忆的这么一个。
特别让我名记的一个地方。
那如果普通人想要在这样一个夏天。
找到自己的队友开启运动。
和身边一起享受运动的快乐。
你们会给大家什么样的建议呢？
就是怎么样让运动。
这件事情能够变得。
更容易更快乐呢？
我觉得其实非常非常简单。
你想要寻找
一起运动的这个搭子。
首先我觉得只要
你先卖开腿
对
因为
队友我觉得
不用去担心
或者去操心
你只要你卖出了那一步。
你的队友已经在
跟你同频的路上了。
所以说我觉得
对于运动来说吧？
因为运动可以让我们感受到。
非常非常多的快乐。
所以说在这个路上。
大家一定会遇到
来自不同地方
或者各个行业
然后各个领域的一些。
跟你一起热爱运动的一些朋友。
然后在之后
你们可以一起向前走。
一起感受运动所带来的。
不同的一些生活体验。
跟一些好的感受
我相信大家在这个之后。
也会对运动
对各种一些项目
有一些新的体验
和一些新的一些态度。
对
我觉得
我刚刚听到顺哥
用了一个词
还有同频的人
就因为我觉得
大家一起愿意去运动。
热爱运动的人
肯定是同频的
所以其实
都不用说太多
其实大家就能够相互知道。
彼此在想什么？
就只要一起开始
就可以了
对
运动对我来说
其实大部分时候
运动不必一个人去完成。
就很多时候
你可以先向你的伙伴。
一起发出邀约
然后你们共同去完成一个目标。
或者去共同去进行一场运动。
那个时候你就会忘记。
身体上所带来的一些酸痛。
让训练不再变得
像坚持一样的去完成它。
会让自己更快乐
有道理
小叶呢？
我的建议就是
可以找一个
跟你有共同的健身喜好的伙伴。
一起这样子
你们做什么训练的时候。
都可以一起做
比较有相互陪伴的感觉。
虽然夏日乐挑战
咱们竞争没有
你们参加奥运会那么激烈。
但对于无论是专业运动员。
还是普通人
作为小小运动员上场的时候。
他们很紧张
压力很大的时候
你们有什么缓解压力。
或者缓解紧张的小方法。
可以与我们分享吗？
其实无论是我觉得。
职业运动员还是专业运动员。
大家一定有非常需要。
面对重要的事情的时候。
感觉跟紧张感
为什么会有这种感觉。
因为你想让自己变得更好。
因为你想要取得
你自己所想要取得那么一个预期。
那一定是在往上构的。
往上构一定是在这里。
所以说你会有这种感觉。
这是因为你想让自己变好的感觉。
我觉得其实我觉得是大家一个。
美好的一个期待
没有期待
你可以用自己的
只容呼吸的一些
调控的一些方式
以及多想想这些过程。
从而去不要太过去焦虑。
想到那个结果
因为过程跟往往
可能结果更重要
对
我觉得紧张的话
其实说明对待这件事情。
它特别的认真
所以说其实不太需要。
关注于紧张这件事情上面。
而是专注于自己
要去做什么？
紧张其实不是那么？
就没那么大的关系了就。
明白明白
何老师呢？
我一般在上台前
我会做一件事情就是深呼吸。
其实所有人都会跟你说。
在紧张的时候做深呼吸。
但是我觉得在运动。
或者比赛的时候是不一样的。
你可以去看一看比赛的终点。
也用眼睛盯着终点的时候。
然后去做一个深呼吸。
剩下当比赛开始的时候。
一切跟着自己的旧记忆走。
做深呼吸的时候
闭上眼睛吗？
刚才小和说的是要看着终点。
对啊？
看着终点做一次深呼吸。
我觉得是一个非常好缓解。
精神压力的方式
我自己的方法也是深呼吸。
然后就是尽量让自己大脑放空。
因为在比赛前
其实你再去想太多。
已经改变不了什么了。
你前期的准备
你觉得自己都已经准备得很充分了。
那这个时候就抛开这一切。
然后也不要太过于去考虑结果。
就是非常专注的
在整一个比赛的过程当中。
我觉得就会让你忘掉那些紧张感。
好的
朋友们也可以收集好。
四位专业运动员给出的这个小建议。
跟朋友一起如何开始训练。
以及在比赛的时候。
面对紧张的状况
我们怎么样来调解。
那今年Lululemon。
他想传递的一个运动精神。
其实就是感受一起的好感受。
所以我们也想在节目的结尾。
回到最核心的那个词。
感受上面
如果让你们四个人。
各自说出一个感受。
那个感受是因为你们在一起。
才会有的这种感受。
而一个人的时候是感受不到的。
你们会怎么样形容这种感受呢？
我们会感受大家在一起。
这种非常难忘的一些瞬间。
一些度过一些困难。
度过一些这种非常让人揪心的瞬间。
这个瞬间有时候可能是好有可能是坏。
但是我们也只有经历过这些东西之后。
大家才能够去感受。
更好的一个自己
更好的一个状态
所以无论好跟坏
我觉得当下永远都是最好的。
也不要去没话咱们。
没有走过那一条路有多好。
当下永远都是最对的一个选择。
对
对我来说
大家一起训练一起比赛。
然后包括一起生活。
这种团队性的运动。
它也会给你产生一种更强的连接感。
然后当大家平时在日常当中。
训练最难的时候
共同去坚持
共同鼓励的时候
进步就不再是个人的。
它更是一个团队的。
更是让你在比赛
面临困难的时候的一个后方力量。
包括练体的时候
在永迟之外的地方。
我们在挥汉
包括彼此基地的时候。
它在增加我们之间的凝聚力。
包括冲弹运动当中的枯燥。
对我来说就是感受。
一起的好感受
我觉得不管是在永迟里也好。
永迟外也好
我们都并肩的去作战。
并肩的训练
并肩的生活
在这个团队当中
不仅有快乐
拥有凝聚力
还有没有彼此的陪伴。
所以说就感觉特别温暖。
我觉得就是队友之间的这种情义。
我用八个字来总结吧？
就是无法复制无法超越。
因为我觉得那么多年的。
互相陪伴一起吃饭一起训练。
然后一起代表神力代表国家参赛。
甚至是一起有同一个接力。
这种情感
我觉得真的是很难。
很难复制也很难超越的。
我们共同经历了很多的困难。
很多的风雨
然后也共同经历了很多的荣誉。
或者说喜悦的时刻。
就是会觉得很难忘吧？
对 我突然想到
就是我们还是要在这个过程中。
去享受这个过程
最后去遵循这个结果。
再遇到那些明知不可为。
而感为的那么一些瞬间的时候。
这个我觉得是一个。
最好的一个感受
特别是遇见困难
然后我们大家一起去通过。
大家非常具有凝聚力的这种精神。
去最后完成这个目标。
这个我觉得是
作为这个好感受的一个。
非常自己的这么一个体会。
对 我觉得你们说的都特别好。
无论是关注当下
关注当下的这种感受和体验。
还是刚才小张说的。
就是大家不仅是并肩作战的队友。
其实也是并肩生活的伙伴。
然后还有诗文刚才说。
就是他是无法复制。
也无法被超越的一种感受。
其实都是这种做队友在一起的感受。
对大家来说都是非常特别的。
一种人生的经验吧？
然后队友跟你一起成长。
也会陪我们共同生活下去。
共同往前走
那今天谢谢四位
跟四位的聊天非常的愉快。
谢谢你们
谢谢
谢谢 辛苦了
今天的对话
让我对一起的好感受。
有了新的理解
一起的好感受
有时候是烦人
有时候是深深的理解和重要的支持。
正是因为跟烦人的队友在一起。
我们也许会发现自己未曾见过的一面。
砰发出自己都一想不到的能量。
也因为有些感受
只有在一起的时候才会有。
谢谢汪顺
叶诗文
张一祥
和何俊逸
谢谢你们的分享
也谢谢每一位收听的朋友。
希望这个夏天
每个人都能找到那个愿意一起动起来。
一起挑战的队友
去感受一起的好感受。
我们下期见吧？
谢谢大家